welcome back to las vegas now there is
still time to get your 2022 priorities
in order okay don't you worry and you
should be at the top of your list it's
so important to take care of yourself so
that you can take care of others too
right so man absolutely lifestyle
experts samantha vickers is back with
some self-care items that can help you
do this successfully so let's start
with the number one all right well you
know that to take care of ourselves yeah
we need good sleep also number one
number one thing right so i brought some
blue living weighted blankets with me oh
my gosh um so these are absolutely
amazing they actually um surround your
body like a gentle hug so they're
they're pretty heavy but yeah go for it
yeah yeah um so they are that's the
children's one so they have all
different sizes and they're actually
filled with glass beads instead of
plastic so they don't retain heat okay
um the the fabric is 100 cotton really
breathable super important here in vegas
we want something that you can use year
round yeah so what it does it feels so
good it does it feels like a big hug
guys it does it does and so what what it
actually does is it it um simulates deep
pressure touch and what that does is it
helps to calm and soothe your body for a
deeper more restful sleep so
blueliving.com check those out this is
great and i'm glad that you pointed out
what kind of beads should be in there
yes you know to make for the best
experience yes absolutely and so they've
got kids ones they've got a throw
they've got comforters for your whole
bed
so yeah obviously
besides sleep this is also good for you
know mental health anxiety things of
that nature that helps with all of those
kind of things yeah i know you can pass
it on to me i don't know
i know we'll throw it back over to here
so also keeping with like de-stressing
all that kind of stuff i've stayed up
too many nights googling you know trying
to get answers to my questions so let's
not do that until my tail expert needs a
lifestyle expert okay
let's instead go to justanswer.com and
this is a membership website and what it
does is it connects you with live
verified vetted experts that's amazing
in over 700 categories you don't need to
stay up all night googling anything
right go to justanswer.com and you're
going to get your get your experts
telling you the real stuff i love for
self-care that's important you need to
ask questions you can't do it all
yourself
exactly okay we women need to take care
of ourselves and part of that is our
hormones right absolutely okay so glow
botanica knows that and they have
created tummy butter cream and it is a
really luxurious naturopathic cream that
helps with pms and menopause discomfort
wow so whatever time of life you're in
yes it does it doesn't matter it's going
to help with all that cramps bloating
hot flashes any kind of mood shifts and
it's going to be something good that you
know that is going to be good for your
body yeah us women always have a little
extra to deal with right physically so
let's move on to this we only have about
40 seconds left so i really want to
touch on this beautiful thing here gem
sarah okay this is gem thera five in one
gemstone p e m f infrared matte it is a
multi-purpose therapy mat um i'm telling
you everyone needs this this is at
jumpthera.com it's got these beautiful
gemstones there's heat therapy there's
light therapy it helps with stress
inflammation um joint pain just
relaxation it is it seriously will like
change your life and can i just add that
it's also beautiful like i just want to
throw it on the on the floor and make
sure no one touches or walks on it i
know i know
as well absolutely gorgeous and i don't
know if i told you guys but this one is
glow botanical.com so okay go botanica
and then gemtherapy.com okay that is
beautiful thank you these are great tips
thank you take care of yourselves this
year it is more important than ever
right absolutely where can people get
more information from you always at
samantha vickers.com okay kendall often
over to you